So, here is this pesky loop that didn't quite work out for us. We want to keep
asking the user to enter a value less than 100 and we want to keep doing it
while they enter a value greater or equal to 100. But really, what we want to
do is we want to go through the loop once. And then, do the check, and then if
the check fails go through the loop again and so on. The key is we want to go
through this at least once, the way to do that in Java is to move the while
statement, the while condition to the bottom and to add the word do to the top.
If there were two on the top, the Y condition on the bottom and this is called
a do loop. Let's look at a program that uses it. So, here's our program. It has
the do loop that you've just seen. So, we keep asking the user, please enter an
integer, less than 100, until they do. In other words, we stay in the loop
while the input is greater or equal to 100, and then this program doesn't do
anything with it. It just says thank you for entering a value less than 100.
Let's, let's run this program so you can see it in action. The program has
started, it asks for an integer less than 100. We'll be annoying and put in
200, we get another prompt and we'll be annoying again. And we could do this
forever, or not. And now, the program simply says thank you for entering 90.
That's the most common reason really to use the do loop for input validation.
And the reason you need the do loop is simply you've got to get at least one
input from the user before you know whether to complain or not. So, this is the
situation where you've got to enter the loop at least once before you know what
to do, that's exactly the point of the do loop. The do loop enters the loop at
least once, whereas the while loop might never enter the loop.